[Musique]
le président du département et les
représentant de l'État se sont rendus à
Saint-Leu pour une signature de
convention de protection du lagon ce
jeudi 29 juin la réserve naturelle
marine qui s'étend de Saint Paul à
L'Étang-Salé protège 80% des récifs
coralliens de Lille et abrite plus de
3500 espèces animales et végétales
aujourd'hui menacé pour pallier à la
dégradation du lagon-saint-leuzien un
diagnostic agricole a permis de mettre
en évidence plusieurs principes
d'aménagement évidemment l'activité
agricole sur la zone des hauts impact
lourdonnement le lagon de Saint-Leu
c'est pour cela que nous devons agir le
département porte la compétence agricole
et dans ce cadre-là en lien bien
évidemment avec les tailles tous les
opérateurs et la municipalité de
Saint-Leu ben nous voulons faire en
sorte que ce qui travaille la terre et
on salue ce travail de la terre dans les
hautes-saint-leu et bien puisse être
accompagné pour que quotidien et surtout
quand il y a de fortes pluies que le
ruissellement des eaux n'en porte pas
toutes les terres que cette terre ne se
retrouve pas dans le lagon nous avons
des moyens nous avons réalisé des études
techniques nous avons aussi la chambre
de la culture qui est un partenaire
historique à nos côtés et bien ensemble
un bon accompagnement pour les
agriculteurs participent eux aussi à la
protection du lagon en travaillant un
peu différemment à protégeant leur terre
surtout en protégeant leur terre porte
le ruissellement des eaux plusieurs
principes d'aménagement ont été
identifiés notamment limiter les
cultures dans certains versants abruptes
mettre en place des barrières
anti-érosives améliorer certaines
pratiques culturelles et mieux
maîtrisées le ruissellement sur les
chemins d'exploitation agricole
[Musique]